-Right now guys, it is time
for "Tonight Show" hashtags.
Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys to respond to
that topic.
So this week I sent out the
hashtag #AddAWordRuinAProduct.
I asked you to take a product
and add one word
to change the meaning.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.,
so thank you for playing along.
Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#AddAWordRuinAProduct tweets
from you guys.
This first is from
@melissamuraco. She says...
[ Laughter ]
You see what it is?
This one is from @christ0phrr.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Luckily it still doesn't
really work.
-No.
This one is from @jentusch.
She says...
-Ooh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Honey nut sack Cheerios?
[ Laughter ]
Wait, what did you just say?
What was that?
-I didn't just say it.
-What did she say?
-Nuttin', honey.
[ Laughter ]
This one -- This one is
from @danimal --
-Ooh!
[ Growls ]
[ Laughter ]
-What's your name? Dan?
No. This is my man, Danimal.
Oh, this is interesting.
-Oh, is it a good one?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You know insoles,
like Dr. Scholl's?
-Yeah, sure. Yeah, something
that keeps your feet --
Like, you stand on.
-Ready to ruin insoles?
-How?
-Lego insoles. There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That hurts. Ow!
-Dan!
-Ow!
Danimal, don't hurt him!
-Danimal!
-Please, Danimal,
don't hurt him.
-[ Coughing ]
-Do you have a loose cough?
-Yeah. Loose cough!
-Okay. This one here is
from @cheytattoos. She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Congratulations.
-Hey!
-Congratulations.
-It's not yours.
-It's in there.
[ Laughter ]
This one is from @starfleetmom.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh, my God. What?
-You can't submit any of these.
-I can't submit any of these?
-No, these are for the --
-You turned all mine down.
-This is for the public.
-Then you read nut sack Cheerios
and ball busters.
Judas Priest.
It's a family show.
-This last one is here
from @michael1701. He says...
There you have it. Those are
our "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.